in A Song of Ice and Fire the long night
was a dark time thousands of years ago
when winter lasted a generation it said
that during this time there was no
daylight and others writing dead horses
and monstrous spiders came from the
north to destroy all living things we
know the long night happened in Westeros
but it also affected the Rhoyne and the
further east so it was probably
worldwide Melisandre says the long night
is coming again bringing an apocalyptic
night that never ends it's starting to
look like she might be right Melisandre
says the only hope is a hero named azor
Ahai people all over the world of Ice
and Fire have stories of the hero who
ended the last long night the
northerners say the last hero joined
with the children of the forest and won
the battle for the dawn against the
others descendants of the Rhoyne are say
a hero convinced their gods to bring
back the day with a secret song the ETS
say a woman with a monkey's tail
restored the Sun the a Shia nameless
hero is or a high and prophesy their
rebirth to save the world once more the
names her kun hero in town if Ariane and
Eldrick shadow chaser are also used
there's also the prince that was
promised some people think the prince
that was promised and azor Ahai are
separate figures but there's no good
reason to think this Melisandre Aemon
Targaryen and Georgia are Martin himself
all talk as those or a high and the
prince that was promised are the same
thing and no one in A Song of Ice and
Fire has ever distinguished between the
two so the prisoner was promised an
azure Ahai reborn appear to be the same
person the stallion who mounts the world
may also be connected he too is
described as a prince and is promised in
prophecy given the blurry overlap and
similarity of this legends it seems
likely that they're all about the same
person the hero who saved the world from
the long night and is prophesied to
return to save the world once more
we'll call him azor Ahai because that's
the best-known name and the easiest to
say so what do we know about azor Ahai
Melisandre says azor Ahai is prophesied
to be born beneath a bleeding star
amidst salt and smoke we hear the same
thing from a Montague area from venero
the high red priest of volantis and from
the mage who says he doesn't trust
prophecy rhaegar targaryen believed in
these prophetic signs and it seems
likely that he's worth earlier and some
of the family members did as well we're
told many times by many people that the
star salt and smoke are signs of azor
Ahai so it seems almost certain that
they truly are
according to Melisandre and a more
another sign is a red or burning sword
called Lightbringer which also appears
in several legends Sam Tolly suggests
that the sword may simply be a Valyrian
steel sword Melisandre says that azor
Ahai will draw the sword from fire one
legend about the original light bringer
says its creation required the
sacrificial execution of azor Ahai his
wife Nissa Nissa as davos speculates it
might be that azor Ahai will have to
make a similar sacrifice but that's
never said to be part of any prophecy so
it might not be important
according to Melisandre Amon and venero
azor Ahai has something to do with
dragons
Melisandre specifically says that azor
Ahai is prophesied to wake dragons from
stone which apparently requires the
sacrifice of someone with Kings blood
since she's the only person claiming
this and she admits that she sometimes
misinterpret prophecies it seems
possible that Melisandre is wrong about
the stone dragons bit but all agree that
azor Ahai is associated with dragons so
that at least seems pretty solid Amon
implies that azor Ahai must have talked
Aryan blood and the ghost of high heart
specifies the line of errors and ariela
to quickly explain that sir Barristan
says that Eris and really Targaryen
married because the woods which said
that the prince that was promised would
be born of their line so Barristan is
description of the woods which matches
the description of the ghost of hai Hut
the mysterious old woman encountered by
IO with the Brotherhood without banners
not only are they both very short women
who produce prophecies but they are both
associated with the children of the
forest and they both were close to
someone named Jenny so they almost
certainly are the same person and the
thing is the ghost of high Hutt has
proven the reliability of her prophecies
by making a lot of really impressive
accurate predictions
therefore beerus turns woods which the
ghost of high heart is almost certainly
correct in saying that as Orihime must
have the blood of heiress and realtor
garyun
a couple more things both Amon and
Rhaegar in a vision say that dragon must
have three heads some people think this
means azor Ahai is three people but
that's not what the text suggests what
the three heads of the Dragon seems to
mean is that azor Ahai should have two
companions who help him out maybe you
ride dragons with them whatever anyone
says that he could have been one of the
three heads if he wasn't so old this
means that the three heads are not
special prophesied figures but can
probably be any Targaryen or anyone at
all the three heads of the Dragon may be
a thing but it's not part of any known
prophecy and it does not mean that three
people are Ozora hi finally Rhaegar
Targaryen in a vision says of the prince
that was promised that he is is the Song
of Ice and Fire again this doesn't seem
to be part of any prophecy and it's very
vague but it's probably worth keeping in
mind so we've got seven signs of azor
Ahai the star the salt the smoke the
sword the sacrifice the stone dragons
and the blood azor Ahai is someone from
the line of Aerys andriola Targaryen
someone born beneath a bleeding star and
amidst salt and smoke they should have a
burning sword and have something to do
with dragons maybe awakening stone
dragons sacrifice might be involved with
the stone dragons or with the sword the
three heads of the Dragon and the Song
of Ice and Fire
may also be involved somehow to find a
Zora hi we must find the person who best
fits this description
Melisandre says that Stannis Baratheon
is a surah high and she tries very hard
to make him fit the seven signs like
every character alive during a clash of
kings
Stannis is around to see the red comet
that appears in the sky and is named the
bleeding star by Danny and the Dothraki
not long after the comet appears is the
ceremony at Dragonstone where statues of
the seven burned and Stannis is
proclaimed to be azor Ahai so this is a
symbolic rebirth of sorts which happens
shortly after if not under a bleeding
star it happens amidst salt and smoke
the salt of the ocean the smoke of the
burning gods
so Stannis has the star smoking salt at
the same ceremony he draws a sword from
fire and names at Lightbringer but as
John points out the swords not warm or
hot as a light bringer should be Iman
says the sword
wrong and describes his flight as an
empty glamour perhaps what magic it has
is another of Miller Sandra's illusions
so as Salladhor saan says that sword was
not Lightbringer as for the sacrifice
Melisandre tries to get Stannis to
sacrifice someone with king's blood in
order to awaken stone dragons so far
that hasn't happened no sacrifice no
dragons Stannis does have some Targaryen
blood but not from Raiola and Eris so he
fails there too that's three out of
seven signs Stannis also has no apparent
connection to the Song of Ice and Fire
all the three heads of the Dragon unless
maybe you want to argue that Stannis
mill and Davos are three heads whatever
that means
so all things considered it looks like
Stannis is not azor Ahai and it wouldn't
fit the story anyway Stannis may be the
Manas but compared to people like Danny
and John he's no hero Stannis is a harsh
bitter unromantic man not a save the
world with a magic sword kinda guy he
says as much himself and come on what
kind of champion of Rolo sets himself on
fire with his own burning sword the fact
that we are led to believe that Stannis
is azor Ahai is a good reason not to
believe that he is azor Ahai why would
George Isle Martin create all this
mystery and prophecy only to tell us the
answer at the start of the second book
as George himself had said prophecies
should not be too literal and too easy
Melisandre has tried and failed to make
Stannis literally fulfilled the azure
Ahai prophecy as Amon says she has
misread the signs she is deceiving
herself because she wants to believe the
evidence strongly suggests that Stannis
Baratheon is not azor Ahai a mom and
venero both say that Daenerys Targaryen
is azor Ahai in the final chapter of
book 1 Daenerys sees the bleeding star
appear walks into flames and amidst
smoke is reborn as the mother of dragons
stone dragons which she wakes from eggs
so straightaway that perfectly fits the
star smoke and stone dragons the salt
probably comes from salty smoky dragon
stone where Danny was literally born if
not from tears or sweat at the pyre
what about Lightbringer you can argue
that Danny's dragons are her fiery
weapon this is supported by Zara's oh
and Dax sauces description of Danny's
fragrance as a flaming sword and when
you think about it as aura high saving
the world with dragons is a lot more
believable than saving the world with
one flaming sword right Peyman says
translation errors are a problem with
this prophecy thinking that light
bringer is a literal sword might be one
of them the awakening of stone dragons
the creation of Danny's burning sword
requires two sacrifices of Danny's love
Drago and of her stillborn son
Rago who has the blood of Targaryen
Kings through Danny
we know these deaths are related to the
birth of Danny's dragons because as
Danny reminds us in the same chapter
only death can pay for life so this
satisfies both kinds of sacrifice of a
loved one for a burning sword like Nissa
Nissa and of king's blood to awaken
stone dragons as male prophecies so i've
got the sacrifice the sword of the stone
dragons that star the smoke the salt and
we've got the blood because Daenerys is
the daughter of Eris and regular
Targaryen
that's all seven signs only the sword is
really questionable the three heads of
the Dragon might relate to Danny's three
dragons three Dragon Riders maybe she
has no clear connection to the Song of
Ice and Fire
but again the song and the heads are
vague and not part of any prophecy
anyway so Daenerys Targaryen fits
everything we reliably know about azor
Ahai and has both a mon and banheiro
backing her it also fits the story for
Danny to be a Zora hi I mean come on she
is Daenerys Stormborn she is the widow
of the Dothraki Karl a mother of dragons
and a sacker of cities she is the
unburnt she is the breaker of chains the
queen of marine queen of the Andals and
the Rhoyne are in the first men lord of
the Seven Kingdoms the fairest woman in
the world she is strong she is fierce
the fire is hers don't know how to put
this but she's out of a big deal
george RR martin has hyped up downey all
series so if anyone's gonna be the
prophesied savior of the world it'll be
her she has the signs it fits the story
Danny is probably azor Ahai but there's
another strong candidate Jon Snow might
be a Zora hi of course last we heard
from him he'd been stabbed four times
but he could be resurrected by
Melisandre we know red priests can do
this from beric Dondarrion and Thoris of
Mir there's evidence that Jon might walk
into his direwolf ghost before returning
to his body
we know Boggs can do this and that John
is unknowingly a powerful walk from The
Dance with Dragons prologue the idea is
supported by
vision that Melisandre has of John in
which he changes from a man to a wolf to
a man again further John's last word
after being stabbed his ghost all this
suggests that John will warg into ghosts
then be reborn a man once more now look
at the passage where John is dead
Jon's wound is smoking bo and marsh is
crying salty tears and Sir Patrick whose
distinctive heraldry features stars is
bleeding a lot
each of these things is emphasized right
at John stabbing the star the smoke the
salt and John brings up the promised
Prince born in smokin salt in the same
chapter as stabbing the star is a bit
dodgy but can this really be a
coincidence let's look at the other
signs John does have a pretty sweet
sword a Valyrian steel sword that hardly
Lightbringer you could argue that the
Nights Watch is his fiery weapon their
vow says I am the sword in the darkness
and they're a weapon against the others
and John Connor sacrifices love yogurt
for them so maybe but again it may be
that the sign of the sword is a
mistranslation or misinterpretation of
the sign of the Dragons in which case
John might need one of Danny's dragons
alternatively John might wake a dragon
from stone by discovering his Targaryen
parentage in the Winterfell crypts there
are some cool theories about reyga's
harp that could help you another is
waking a dragon from within the wall but
both of these are just future
speculation for now John has no dragon
probably no sword and probably no
sacrifice but these are things that
could happen later we've still got two
books coming now if R plus L equals J is
true and it very probably is John has
the blood that would also literally make
him the prince that was promised and
would make him of Ice and Fire
so joint satisfies most of the signs of
azor Ahai less than Danny but there's
strong additional evidence that John is
azor Ahai Melisandre says that when she
tries to say you're Zora hi inner flames
roll or shows us snow as in Jon Snow
this happens repeatedly must be pretty
frustrating for role or that Melisandre
never makes the connection right
although John has a dream in which he
wields a burning red sword against the
others at the wall he shouts about fire
and even slays the woman he loves with a
red sword these are some pretty strong
hint
right so there's a lot of evidence
suggesting that Jon Snow is azor Ahai
and it would make narrative sense to
John clearly is someone special as
indicated by his white day wolf and even
his bastardy which has always marked him
as someone who is different
he's a heroic figure brave honorable
determined to do what's right and he's
already fighting the others which is
what azor Ahai does it makes a lot of
sense for John to via Zora hi
so Stannis is probably not azor Ahai the
evidence points to Danny and also to
John looks like that both azor Ahai the
Song of Ice and Fire right but let's
look at other possibilities could there
be a third azor Ahai Aegon if he really
is Aegon has the blood and apparently
the star Rhaegar also had the blood and
was born amidst salt and smoke Victarion
has a burned smoking hand Davos was
reborn amidst salt and smoke the
lightning Lord has a burning sword
Brienne has a red sword
Tyrion makes a nice trio with Danny and
John Ramsay has the name snow Jaime
goodness and Nyssa Cersei Jaber goodness
and Nyssa Danny hot pie bakes salty
pyres in smoky ovens and pretty piggies
is Pam you can find some connections and
possibilities for almost any character
but only Danny and John are strongly
supported by evidence only Danny and
John have important signs like the blood
the star salt and smoke only Danny and
John have heaps of the shadowing hints
and visions it would be bad storytelling
to spend the whole series focusing on
Danny and John before going hey by the
way this guy this guy Aegon or this guy
[ __ ] Ramsay snow he's also a savior
of the world
it would also ruin the nice little Song
of Ice and Fire we've got going with
John and Danny so a third azor Ahai is
not impossible but it seems unlikely and
there's really no good reason to believe
it another argument you can make is that
no one is azor Ahai the prophecy is
wrong or irrelevant but it would be even
worse than a third Ozora hire to build
up all this fish shadowing all these
visions and hints and then throw them
away and say they meet nothing azor Ahai
doesn't have to be a perfect fairytale
hero who makes everything better
we know prophecies a [ __ ] we know
things are complicated but with all this
evidence azor Ahai has to mean something
there are other objections and
convoluted complications that you could
raise but everything we currently know
about azor Ahai points to two people
John and Danny Danny fits the prophecy
almost perfectly John fits most of it
and has extra hints on top John and
Danny are the two main characters
together representing Ice and Fire the
title of the series based on what we now
know the most reasonable conclusion to
come to is that Danny and John are Ozora
hi and are prophesied to save the world
from a night that never ends thanks for
watching
subscribe if you'd like to see more
you